well i was always called when i was
young
as the self-styled
genius i all i heard about was the
self-style
genius so i that's what i took seriously
that i was styling myself a genius and
you know anybody can do that toast
jedediah to love on my terms
those are the only times anybody ever
knows you know my first picture would
never have been made
never in a million years if the producer
had lived in hollywood
had any knowledge of hollywood it was a
total accident
total piece of luck like winning six
hundred thousand dollars
from a quarter in a with a jackpot and
it couldn't go on and i knew that
because they
they they took my next picture away from
me and butchered the end of it
i was going to show them that they were
wrong
and i have spent the rest of my life
showing people
trying to prove that what is said is
wrong
and that's been an enormous waste of
spirit and of energy
that's a mistake that will be corrected
one of these days well i've always hated
hollywood
but i hate almost everything in the
modern world
and hollywood is simply the most
pleasant place to live in left
i don't know how to run a newspaper mr
fetcher i just try everything i can
think of
you know i am a romantic and i was a
romantic in the early 19th century
way i wanted every experience every kind
of thing and so i went to hollywood in
that spirit
and i should have left in that spirit
there's only one person in the world to
decide what i'm going to do and that's
me
i don't believe there is any wisdom in
compromise
unless you're a politician and to the
extent that movies
are politics i don't belong in movies
my pictures don't work at all unless
they work my way it's not because
i think they're better that way they
simply fall apart
unless they're done my way so it isn't
nobility
it's self-protection you're right mr
thatcher i did lose a million dollars
last year i expect to lose a million
dollars this year i expect to lose a
million dollars next year
you know mr thatcher at the rate of a
million dollars a year i'll have to
close this place in
60 years ask anybody of my age
what they feel about themselves when
they're young i think you'll get a very
waffly answer i think of myself of
having been an awfully nice fellow then
and i may have blacked out you know
whole
sections of dreadful behavior but i've
genuinely blocked them out i don't
remember them i just see myself
as angelically moving from one show to
another
i think i did pretty well under the
circumstances i am going to make king
lear
and a picture called the dreamers and
i'll go on saying that until i don't
but it looks as though i it's going to
happen but you know i've had a wonderful
fascinating life i can't complain i'm
the luckiest person i know
and i'd rather be remembered as a good
guy than as a difficult genius